Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Gravity Cat
Now, its been a while since I played a good ol' fashion platformer.
And I don't imagine that I've gotten any better at it
So let just try and see what's gonna happens when we hit play.
That's a lot of levels, holy shit.
So as is with any platformer, Oh, It's got a story!
What a beautiful day!
Scarcely! I steal your blue eyes-
Oh my god! *laughs*
What? You stole its eyes?!
I didn't know  that it was gonna be
starting out like that.
Okay... for the game need a plot
Ohh... So anyway, gravity cat is based on the
principle that you flip- well shit!
You flip gravity upside down, and at least
there's not a horrible spurt of blood
well off I go off then, into the distance.
So, it's- damn it- at least,
yeah, I mean I would have expected with
saw blades that there would have been
like an explosion of blood after every
single time that I died, but thankfully
No.
and then you hit lasers I guess that- ahh!
because- ah fuck! God dammit, I don't know
what I'm doing just yet and I'm
embarrassing myself and also it's very
early in the morning and I have no idea
what I'm doing - oh, hello
(Marky, focus!)
Okay, so this is basically the principal of the entire game and I imagine that it's
going to get more and more complicated
but the reason that I saw it or the
reason that it caught my eye is because,
well, cats are adorable I guess and for
(Say that to Chica, Mark.)
some fucking reason I was drawn this one because it looked cute or whatever
I don't need to justify myself to you I do exactly what I want to do
What did that do?
Oh, okay. HE-AHH. Ohh, damn it.
Hi-uup- and it's got pretty decent music if
I have to say so
Huzzah! we're gonna keep going on and on and on to try to steal back this cat's
eyes which is as good a plot device as any
that I've seen.
Heya! Ah
fuck me then, god dammit this is gonna be
harder than I thought
Ah jeezums and the games got like two game
modes
I got to remember not to jump and
actually use the gravity
Okay, all right then
Yeah!
Not entirely complicated up to this
point, but I think I think I've got a
good handle on this.
Huh, I just gotta think making with
gravity
Tada! Okay, hello. Man, I'm getting super meat
boy vibes with these saw blades and all
this stuff which you know a lot of- whaa
fuck! Which a lot of people have been
asking me- or ask me not lately- asked me
over the years to play super meat boy
but a long time ago and there's still
like,  there's a hidden other chan-
This is a weird revelation of make for you
guys to discover this
but there's like a hidden channel of
mine
(WOAH WHAT THE FRICK!?!?)
um... that no one really knows about anymore
it's called markiplier livestream
highlights and it was a channel that i just made for, like, highlighting
live streams that I did because way, way, way
back in the day I did live streams a lot
more than i did now and, oh no,
it was called  Markiplier livestream
archives and it still exists it's still
out there I, I don't know what happened
to it- I haven't- I don't even know if
that channel is like, I'm able to even log
into it anymore, not that it matters.
um, but yeah, I played Super Meat Boy a
whole bunch on that, and I played like
Day-Z, and- why this is a weird revelation
to have to, like, announce
this whole lost thing of mine there's-
there's hours of content
I remember I like I - I played,
umm...
I played uhh...
Aww man, what's it called?
Max Payne. I played Max Payne. I played a whole bunch of Max Payne and I tried to beat it on, uh... the
hardest difficulty and I did it and I
believe the archive is up there and a
man, just a whole bunch of like, ooold stuff.
Man, I haven't even thought about that in
forever
I need to go to look that up because
I completely forgot that exists
I haven't even given that a thought in
years so if i find it
Um, I'll put a link in the description
(I guess I'll have to subtitle those, too... ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) )
because... god damn, it totally
blew my mind that even existed
Oh, and by the way, this game is adorable.
A- and kind of fun I will admit like the
reason I'm playing this is because I found
it on steam and, and, and drew me to it
because obviously happy cat visuals seem
pretty cool to me, um, but other than that
you know, I haven't played, like, a
difficult or challenging platformer and
this one is delightful!
I mean it's, it's obviously not a lot to- ahh shit -
it's obviously not a lot to it
but- eh!- there we go.
Eh! Eh! Well, yeah, but it's pleasant. Poop!
Fuck.
Aah shit
Yeah, I can scale through
this
Aah, what! What happened? What happened?
Ah damn it, come on! God damn it! Why do i
keep getting stuck on that corner, let me
go through! Is that not how I'm supposed to do this? Seems like I'm supposed to do this.
Hyeaah!
Nah, can't do that. Get- aagh.
Haa, there we go, okay- then just jump
'cause I'm all gravity'ed up. Hyup! Oh boy.
Am I supposed to reverse gravity here?
Hyep- dammit! God dammit! It's so stu-
It's not stupid, I'm stupid because I
don't know how to play the game, but- hyap!
Oooh, come on. There we go. Hyup
Okay, get that, go back over here, hyup
There we go, okay, we got it. All right, nooow
I'm getting it! Now I am the smart!
Heah- heaah! I mean, the last time that I played
a puzzle platformer with adorable cats
like this was probably Bloody Trapland,
and that one just has a
biiit more death and destruction to it,
which is more my flavor when I play
these games.
Oh god I gotta do this again. Aaah! Oh my
god. Don't do that to me, that one was
actually challenging
I mean, I know the whole point of this is
to get more and more challenging as time
goes on, but, you know, sometimes I like
the easy route!
I like not to think about what I'm doing
before I'm doing things, and also it's
very early in the morning- and god dammit. Aaah,
son-of-a-bitch.
Woop-woop-woop-woop-woop-woop-hyup! HYEAH!
Wah- weoooh. Oh weeeh. Oh, okay.
Woop! Heeeyah! Okay. Man- this is gonna- this is actually
kind of hurting my brain
uh, I don't need to use gravity all the time,
but I understand that the main point of it is
to use the gravity, but, I gotta remember-
god damn- flipping upside down like this
like- I'm not a smart guy
I, I, I mean I was gonna be an engineer or
whatever.
How am I supposed to thi- aah! Ah, son-of-a-tits. Hush
your face with the happy-go-lucky music!
How am I supposed to do this?
Damn it! Because I can't- I can't reverse
gravity in midair
I have to be touching the ground to be
able to reverse gravity. Ehahn- I also haven't
pondered the conundrum of why this cat
is able to manipulate gravity at will!
I mean I know cats are mysterious and
probably devilish in horrible mysterious
ways and from another dimension, but I
don't know if they'd be able to do all
this mysterious stuff they got here.
Hyeh! Fucking dammit. God, cock, and ass.
Ugh! Music's too happy for me to be slightly
frustrated at all this.
Not raging yet, and I don't think this game
is gonna give me the raging levels, but
it just seems like- agh. There's a lot of precision
required which is a factor in- in these
platforming style bullshit games, but
it's whatever.
God damn it, how are you supposed to be
able to do that?! Fucking cock!
Oh, fuck, man. There's no other way besides
flipping right there, but it's- it's- it's
overly precise.
Maybe if I get like right on the... Eh. Oh fu-
Fuuu-  I'm clooose!
Ugh, why is this one so stupidly precise!? And
how is it supposed to get more difficult
from here?
AGH! Fucking! cock! Son of a biscuit. God
damn it's- it's not that bad
Ugh, man god damn it. It's not that bad
it's- UGH! Fucking criminy Christmas!
Ugh, I'm- I'm getting like, physically frustrated
more than anything, like, a little *incoherent Mark noises*
Ah! OOOHOHH!
YES! Okay I'm done! Fuck that, man! I don't
want to do anymore with that, it's too
early!
Ah, it's too early. But either way, that is
gravity cat. If you understand the
basic principle of gravity cat and
platforms you'll probably enjoy this one
and, it just- it just seems like this one
requires a hefty amount of freaking
precision- I, I needed to use gravity for that.
I don't know why I didn't use gravity
for that. I'm a freaking fool if I didn't
use gravity for that. It's obviously
gravity requiring the gravity cat, and that's
what gravity means when your gravity can
your gravity crap
it's gonna be gooood! And everything else
besides it's gonna fall into place
you're gonna have a lot of fun playing
gravity cat. I don't know.
Found it on steam, it was super duper
cheap, I played if you want. There's a lot
of levels and whatnot
oooh, this is how it's gonna be. Heehleheh. Blebblehbleh
Okay there we go. And, boink! Well, that one was
much easier than the last one and I-
AAAAHHHH!!
*laughs*
Okay, so that's all for gravity cat. I'm
just gonna let him die repeatedly here
and waste all of his nine lives- or
however many lives he has in this
endeavor and, also, if I find my old...
youtube channel you can watch quite a
bit of content of old baby Markimoo
way back before I knew what I was doing,
so... I'm sorry for what you're about
to see, but if I find it I'll put the
link in the description below so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
As always... I'll see YOU...
in the next video!
BUH-BYE!!